zoom versus primes which are better
yeah there's
so zoom lenses and prime lenses they
both have pros and cons uh for sure and
um it's a big
it's a big subject um
traditionally zoom lenses are slower so
uh
meaning you can't let as much light in
or they need you to have more light
whereas prime lenses this is not a rule
it's just traditionally it's how it lays
out so prime lenses tend to be faster
so you know in terms of a t-stop or an
f-stop
you can open up more uh and let and have
a shallower depth of field let more
light in
but you a prime lens you know is like a
25 millimeter and that's all it is 25 is
a 25
whereas a zoom
let's say because there's also a huge
range of zooms you can have a 25 to 78
or you can have a 25 to 250
and when these lens you know and some of
these zooms are huge
so
there's a l there's a lot of decision
making that goes into what lenses you're
using
and the prime versus zoom is one of the
big ones uh
there's also speed so if you're shooting
on
let's say a reality tv show you pretty
much have to have a zoom lens because
you need to be able to go in and it
doesn't mean you're zooming in during a
shot though it could but it also just to
reset is you know you have a wide shot
and then you adjust your body however
you can but you don't want to be in the
way so if you want to get a close-up on
a reality show
you just zoom in from where you are
uh that's kind of like the the very
broad strokes
but there's a lot you know the
like a dolly move versus a zoom in
they have a different feel to them and
what's happening to the background is
very different and where your character
or your subject in space the way
a zoom is you zoom in it tends to it
flattens the image whereas if you're on
a prime if you're on a 35 millimeter and
you're moving in everything is still
staying you're able to isolate
characters more so there are a lot of
qualities
that they're so difficult to see and
feel and i'm very lucky because
last five years i've been shooting so
much
so now i am at a place where a 20 what a
24 millimeter does to a
you know let's say a medium close-up
shooting that if you
shoot this on a 24 millimeter from right
here
and then you move it back
just six inches and you put on a 28
millimeter
i for me there's a big difference
between the two but it's taken
just hours you know so many hours on set
and and looking through different lenses
and watching their effect
is what it does to the image some of it
you can explain like if i'm moving my
hands
and i'm on a 25 millimeter it's going to
be exaggerated my face will be a little
rounder what does that mean it makes me
feel maybe a little more silly or a
little more cartoonish but if you move
back and even though this the the top
and bottom of the frame are exactly the
same on a 50 millimeter
none of those things are exaggerated
anymore it's almost a little like a 50
would be
normal
and so
that becomes a tool
and so then within that you're you're
deciding like a prime versus a zoom what
is worth
what are your trade-offs because on a
zoom you can reset really quickly
but primes tend to have more character
to them or be cleaner or you know so
that it's it's all pros and cons and and
it's you know it's just like
if you're if you're grabbing grabbing
paints if you're painting your house you
know and they have those swatches
there's like yellow but really it's like
this is goldilocks this one's dandelion
this and they have such subtle
differences but there are differences
and that's what lenses kind of bring
they all have different characteristics
and
zoom and prime are the two big
categories but then even within that
there are
a number of different things that will
differentiate one from another and and
you know time money
resources
are part of that decision it's not all
purely aesthetic
a lot of it is like well we won't have
time to change primes or
whatever like we need to be able to
hustle hustle hustle um
yeah so it's yeah there's there's a lot
there's a lot in there
what's a what's a good starting lens
aside from like sort of the stock camera
lens that's going to come with the body
what would you recommend if somebody
wants to upgrade just a little bit
yeah i mean
well
so i think you know choosing a lens if
you're starting
if you could only start with one lens
one size and this is assuming because
different cameras have different size
sensors
so a 35 millimeter lens
does
the lens is always the lens but if your
sensor like our phones have a very small
sensor
so
a 35 millimeter on the well that's maybe
a bad way to start that
a 35 millimeter is always the lens is
the lens
but if you have a large sensor then a 35
millimeter plays very wide and if you
have a smaller sensor
then a 35 millimeter plays a little
tighter
so your camera but the sort of standard
size is
super 35 is the first sensor so that's
what most things are
and
i would say assuming you have one of the
more common cameras
that i would choose between a 35 or a 50
as the i would lean 35 but i know most
people would lean 50.
and i think that's because they're
close-ish to
our vision or at least that's how people
say because really in reality if you pay
attention i'm looking at you but i'm i
can see my peripheral vision is pretty
wide
so you could argue oh that's a 25
millimeter but my attention is really on
you
and you could argue that that means that
i'm not really watching the outskirts
and so really that's a 50 millimeter
and so it's it's you know it depends now
for me a 35 millimeter is a really nice
size because you can shoot a wide and
you can shoot a close-up
but if you get in close on a 35
it does have a little roundness to it
so
it's yeah maybe maybe the answer is a 42
which is a hard lens size to find but
yeah i think those are the
normal hero sizes i would say is a 35
and a 50 i think would be the two
sizes
that
one would start with i think
what's the best way to take care of the
lenses so they're not scratched
different elements yeah working with
sand for sure yeah lenses require a lot
i mean you need to treat lenses like a
like a baby like they are they are even
though a lot of them are built very
rugged the glass is glass
and so you know i'm very lucky i have a
great camera team and so i rarely touch
a lens you know my first ac second ac
they bring it on they take everything
out there they're
you know
they take everything out with care
they've they're also professionals
they've been doing it for years so
but you do need to treat a lens you need
to be constantly looking at when you
take it off and you put it on you need
to check both sides up against the light
because dust particles get in there and
if a dust particle is in the wrong part
of frame
it will affect your image sometimes
dramatically
so you really need to take care of them
some people will have a
uv filter which is basically just
clear glass it does it functionally it
does serve a bit of a purpose but really
i did that for a long time i've gotten a
little away from it now
uh but i have a set of rokinons which
are cheap lenses
uh but i think the best bang for the
buck they don't have a ton of
personality
but they are
really good for their price like a
rokinon lens and you can get ones that
have
gears on them so if you're using a
follow focus
and those are like
i think for a and they're really fast
really fast
uh i think they're like 200 bucks for a
lens and for a good lens with gears on
it that's really fast
uh i think that's the the best lens you
can get in terms of somebody beginning
and i would just choose one of those if
you can
and
yeah i think that's
i think that's where i'd start i still
have mine and they used to have those
filters on top in terms of protecting
them
but now that i'm more comfortable and
i'm like i'm probably not going to screw
this thing up
i i don't have live on there but you
know if you're shooting out in the woods
or shooting at the beach or in the
desert is a
nightmare for lenses and for camera
sensors it just gets in gears it gets in
the fan and you you everything needs to
be protected and sometimes that's
putting plastic or fabric around it and
yeah film equipment strong as it is you
still need to treat it very gently